digamos que me encuentro en esta nave
espacial y no digamos yo soy este
personaje
y me encuentro viajando en el espacio en
esta nave espacial y digamos también que
tengo una amiga digamos que tengo una
amiga que también se mueve en una nave
espacial y que desde mi marco de
referencia tiene cierta velocidad que va
a ser igual a 8 décimas partes de la
velocidad de la luz es decir su
velocidad será 0.8 por la velocidad de
la luz y una pregunta que yo tengo para
ti es tratar de ver si es posible que
pueda digamos existir un tercer
personaje o quizás otro grupo de
personas que también viajen en una en
una nave espacial verdad donde ahora la
velocidad de esta tercera nave espacial
digamos desde mi marco de referencia ok
va a estar entre el reposo que es
digamos el estado en el que yo me
encuentro
y la velocidad que lleva esta nave es
decir 0.8 veces la velocidad de la luz
muy bien pero además esta nave espacial
debe ser tal que desde su propio marco
de referencia tanto el personaje como el
personaje me lleven digamos a la
velocidad lleven velocidades con la
misma magnitud aunque puede ser que
vayan en direcciones contrarias el
chiste es que digamos tengan la misma
rapidez muy bien entonces en esencia lo
que estamos diciendo esto es digamos
viéndolo desde la referente desde el
marco de referencia en este caso sería
desde mi marco de referencia es decir
del del personaje a pero el objetivo es
que si lo vemos desde el marco de
referencia del personaje c entonces este
personaje se encontrará en reposo verdad
sin embargo lo que va a ocurrir con
ahora mi nave espacial que es la del
personaje
y entonces ahora se mueve a una
velocidad distinta verdad por ejemplo si
suponemos que la velocidad del personaje
se desde mi marco de referencia era ve
entonces desde él desde el marco de
referencia del personaje se el personaje
a llevar a una velocidad de menos ve muy
bien en cambio que es lo que va a pasar
con con el otro personaje con el
personaje c bueno estamos tratando de
ver si es posible que este personaje se
lleve cierta velocidad de tal suerte que
desde ese marco de referencia tanto a
cómo ve lleven la digamos la velocidad
con magnitud y magnitudes iguales
entonces en este caso b se tendrá que
mover hacia la derecha con velocidad v
verdad entonces esto es bastante
interesante en realidad la pregunta es
podemos determinar quién es esta
velocidad de entonces por ejemplo en un
mundo digamos galilea no podríamos
pensar qué
es la velocidad entre estos dos verdad
sería en este caso por ejemplo pensemos
que si estamos en una autopista entonces
digamos que yo me encuentro en reposo y
tengo una digamos un carro que se mueve
a 80 kilómetros por hora
entonces la velocidad que debe llevar
este tercer personaje será 40 kilómetros
por hora verdad y así la velocidad
digamos la mía y la del personaje b será
de 40 kilómetros por hora ya sea hacia
la derecha o hacia la izquierda verdad
pero en esencia aquí vivimos en un
universo definido por la relatividad
especial entonces este este argumento no
es válido así que te invito a que hagas
una pausa y trates de descubrir por tu
propia cuenta quién tendría que ser esta
velocidad v muy bien y te voy a dar una
pista la la forma de resolver este
problema involucra la fórmula de
einstein para la suma de velocidades
muy bien entonces vamos a resolver este
problema para lo cual creo que conviene
primero recordar cómo es la fórmula de
einstein para la suma de velocidades
verdad entonces el cambio en x prima
dividido entre el cambio entre prima
será igual a
- b / / 1 - por b sobre se cuadrada
verdad y esta es digamos la fórmula
general ahora bien la clave de todo esto
es ver digamos esta fórmula pero desde
el punto de vista o desde el marco de
referencia de nuestro personaje sé muy
bien entonces si pensamos por ejemplo en
quién sería b si estamos desde el marco
de referencia del personaje c entonces b
sería la velocidad la velocidad digamos
de nuestro personaje o de la velocidad
de nuestro personaje a moviéndose
moviéndose desde
desde ce
desde ese entonces en esencia sería la
velocidad de a que se está moviendo de
verdad digamos en este caso hacia la
izquierda desde el personaje sé muy bien
y por supuesto esto lo tenemos que
pensar en la referencia en digamos en el
marco de referencia del personaje ce así
que solo lo voy a poner como en la
referencia d
muy bien ahora quién sería en este caso
pues en este caso sería la velocidad la
velocidad de nuestro personaje ve
moviéndose moviéndose desde ce desde
desde sé muy bien entonces sería la
velocidad de nuestro personaje ve que se
mueve a la derecha es decir se mueve
desde nuestro personaje se y otra vez
esto está visto en el marco de
referencia de nuestro personaje sé muy
bien entonces ahí lo tenemos y con esto
ahora ya podríamos ver quién tendría que
ser el cambio en x prima dividido entre
el cambio en de prima verdad porque en
este caso estaríamos cambiando digamos
de más es la velocidad en otro marco de
referencia en este caso sería la
velocidad debe de nuestro personaje ve
moviéndose desde digamos la posición del
personaje a verdad pero esto ya está
visto en el marco de referencia de a
entonces vamos a escribir eso esto es la
velocidad del personaje ve moviéndose
moviéndose desde desde digamos la
ubicación del personaje
y por supuesto esto está en el marco de
referencia de a así que simplemente lo
voy a escribir de esta forma en digamos
es desde el marco de referencia de a muy
bien entonces quizás esto puede
parecerte un poco confuso verdad pero
solo es cosa de que recuerdes en los
vídeos anteriores recuerdas la fórmula
de einstein para la suma de velocidades
y veas que en efecto es digamos la
interpretación de esta fórmula desde el
marco de referencia de c ahora bien lo
que nosotros tenemos es esto verdad
nosotros sí sabemos cuál es la velocidad
del personaje ve moviéndose desde el
personaje a de hecho sabemos que es 0.8
veces la velocidad de la luz así que
vamos a escribirlo
esto será 0.8
verdad y según esta fórmula será igual a
vamos a ver y tendría que ser la
velocidad debe moviéndose desde ce en la
digamos en el marco de referencia de c y
esa velocidad es de verdad o quizás
deberías decir v
v y luego restamos menos menos la
velocidad de a moviéndose desde ce en el
marco de referencia de ser pero en este
caso la velocidad es menos ve menos sube
más bien muy bien y quizás esto se pueda
confundir verdad cómo es que sustituimos
b por menos b pero bueno recuerda que
esta es la fórmula general aquí
simplemente estamos sustituyendo los
valores correspondientes muy bien
entonces esto va dividido entre 1 - el
producto de eeuu por b en este caso
sería sería b y la vejez en realidad
sería menos b entonces el producto sería
menos de cuadrada menos b cuadrada
dividida entre pse cuadrada muy bien así
que ahora podemos en realidad resolver
esta ecuación que hemos obtenido al
tratar de hallar el valor
y la clave en este problema es
justamente pensar que debe haber otra
nave es verdad que se mueve a cierta
velocidad v de tal suerte que de que
desde su marco de referencia se muevan
tanto en la nave como la nave se muevan
alejándose de él con velocidades de
igual magnitud así con esta información
usamos la fórmula de einstein verdad
para la suma de velocidades pero en
lugar de saber quiénes serían y para
calcular digamos esta otra velocidad
entonces tenemos lo contrario de hecho
sabemos sabemos esto verdad sabemos
quién es delta x prima entre delta t
prima verdad y además sabemos que tanto
esta velocidad como v tienen la misma
magnitud verdad y que de hecho supusimos
que en realidad es v verdad y de esta
forma podríamos tratar de calcular cuál
es ese valor que no conocemos verdad y
eso en realidad lo haremos en el
siguiente vídeo para lo cual te invito a
que trates de resolverlo por tu propia
antes de ver el siguiente vídeo